bori state television is reporting a
missile was intercepted over the capital
Riyadh another missile has reportedly
hit the southern coastal city of jisan
on the Red Sea near the border with
Yemen and let's bring in the editor of
Arab digest bill law he joins us live
via Skype from Glasgow good to have you
with us here on the news er this is of
course a developing story details are
still coming in but if these missiles do
we're hearing from Saudi a state media
that missiles have been intercepted what
would be your initial reads on this
situation who is likely to have been
behind this well I think it's very clear
that it's a bootys who are behind it the
Houthis have been engaged in an
offensive over the past couple of weeks
they've just taken al Jeff governor
which is next door to Saudi Arabia in
the north of Yemen they're threatening
another governor it matters which is the
oil-producing region of Yemen so they
are running hard and fast right now
so I think it's it's very clear to me at
any rate that these will not come from
that Houthis this is a message if you
will to the Saudis that you are
vulnerable to us and we have the
capability to hit you pretty well
anywhere we would choose the Houthis
have fired many many many missiles into
Saudi Arabia over the course of at least
the last two years and some of them have
been intercepted others have fallen
perilously close to the Riyadh Airport
others have hit facilities needs to
province around Co facilities so the
Houthis are sending a message here and
would it would certainly appear to be so
in terms of the this strike and the fact
that they've managed to get missiles if
this is indeed the Hootie's they managed
to get missiles up to Riyadh which isn't
next door to Yemen
well what does this say about the the
strength of the the Hootie's right now
does this suggest that they are gaining
a momentum gaining in strength at this
time yes I think it does and I think the
Houthis have already shown they have the
capability to fire missiles at at great
distance and and hit via and and other
and other parts of Saudi Arabia not just
the portion of Saudi Arabia that's
adjacent to Yemen and I think that they
are as I said on an offensive they are
staking out a claim now who knows who
this elite we do know the Saudis are
very anxious to find a way out of this
war Mohammed Salman younger brother
Khalid bin Salman has been attempting to
find a road to peace not very
successfully at all this I think simply
raises the ante
the Saudis of course are engaged in an
oil price war with the Russians they
themselves are dealing with the
coronavirus issue they are in a
situation where the Houthis I think I've
judged that we can as I said send them a
reminder that we're here and we can hit
you pretty much anywhere that we want to
the good news I suppose is that at least
one of these was intercepted so that the
the Saudis are have the ability to take
out these missiles previously they were
showing themselves not particularly good
at that you recall the the attack on the
Aramco facilities last September the
pinpoint attack really which the Saudis
simply did not wake up to before was far
too late so the Saudis I suppose you
could say the good news out of this for
them is that they did at least intercept
the one missile over area you mentioned
earlier that the message the Houthis
were perhaps sending to the Saudis is
that you are vulnerable we are in the
midst of this appalling Karuna virus
pandemic where everybody
it would appear is vulnerable what do
you make of the timing of this attack
given that we are all so consumed by
this deadly pandemic
that's sweeping the entire go well I
think the timing is it's quite ruthless
isn't it the Houthis themselves Yemen is
facing a coronavirus crisis the Houthis
do not seem to be particularly concerned
in any way about the civilian population
they've already shown that in terms of
the way in which they withheld
humanitarian food and medicine they
clearly see this as an advantage to play
regardless of the situation with
coronavirus either in Yemen or in Saudi
Arabia
okay below the editor of Arab digest
great to get your thoughts thank you so
much for your analysis and thank you for
joining us there live from Glasgow